dog theft increased by 20 during the
pandemic with the equivalent of seven
dogs a day being taken across 2020. now
one director has decided to document
what it means to the detectives trying
to crack down on the rise even talking
to some of those stealing our beloved
pets let's take a look these ones
are about three grand a pot
these bigger ones here seven grand
thinking about putting things in place
for my little ones or when they grow up
they might be able to have the
opportunities that weren't immediately
available to me girl and i guess i've
just prioritized
my own gains
i'd be a fool to tell you i'm doing this
for any other reason
i wouldn't
producer and director of the film and
the pet detective himself colin butcher
hello to you both
good morning good morning it's good to
see you see this makes my blood boil the
very thought of somebody stealing my
dogs in order to make money out of it is
infuriating can there ever
colin be a reason for that to be
acceptable
no no um
[Music]
at the end of the day
if you have concerns about any diverse
further then you just simply contact the
police you don't take the law into your
own hands but the trade in puppies is
out of control and it's only going to
get worse
this is so much money that people can
make in trading illegally
um
baer why do they do it
um they do it because there's such a
demand game so you know that the film
looks at
our social media gratification it looks
at our obsession with celebrity culture
and i think that um the more i
investigated and looked into this this
subject that's why i realized that
people are just
um
they do it because there's so much money
to be made and because there's there's
so much to want
okay there was suggestions that some
people do in order to make money in
order to feed their families is is that
the case and is that a reasonable excuse
i suppose my audience would be asking
this morning
i
to be honest i don't think there's any
excuse to
um
to to be part of any sort of like
nefarious activities i think what i was
trying
what the film does is it tries to
show all
members all contributors as free as
three dimensionally as it can and so you
don't have to like these individuals but
whilst you're watching the film for the
11 minutes you have to at least hear
them out hear their motivation to hear
their their methods and and try and have
some sort of understanding of who they
are as people
colin what happens when you manage to
recover a dog and then you take it back
to the family
that is what keeps me going through many
many cold wintry nights that the reunion
at the end of the day
is is the very very special moment what
i do
and but to add what
was just said a few minutes ago
there's no excuse for stealing a dog at
least leaves families deeply traumatized
and there's plenty of support within the
community you don't have to go out and
commit crime
but
when you start focusing on dogs it's a
member of people's families it's really
really traumatic
when a dog is stolen there's never an
excuse for doing it
no i remember one of my dogs being
stolen 25 years ago and i can still
remember exactly how i felt about it
at the time
what common mistakes do people make that
allows people to steal their dogs
a dog can only be stolen really when
he's unsupervised
so
people
are a little bit careless or they let
their guard down and they take the dog
for a long walk and they pop the dog
into a car at the end of the walk
or they're distracted easily or they
allow the dog to run out of sight you
have to remember now that dogs are very
very valuable to a thief
and
always assume that somebody is watching
so just keep your dog supervised it's
very very difficult to steal a dog that
is actively supervised
and can i also add as well um a thief
that i spoke to so that
i spoke to more than one thief
whilst making this film and the first
told me that he would literally go to
green spaces look for dogs off their
leash leashes he'd always be
accompanied by
a female to look inconspicuous he'd go
over a pet a dog play with it pick it up
look the owner in the eye and say don't
follow me and jog off in the other
direction so brazen intimidation broad
daylight so i think you have to be
vigilant because you know sometimes it
can be your own common mistake sometimes
you might just find someone who as i say
will just use intimidation to try and to
try and sort of rest your dog away from
you
yeah um and if you've also got your baby
with you you know you what are you going
to do you've got to look after the baby
and then somebody's making off with your
dog i just don't i can't even begin to
imagine bear how do we see the movie how
do we see this uh short film that you've
made
um so it's actually it's it's the first
um
film to be launched on tick tock
initially on friday at 7 p.m
and then on
on sunday it will be launched on
netflix's youtube um channel um at 2 p.m
so
yeah watch it tell a friend to tell a
friend let's try and as i say raise
awareness galvanize and kickstart a
movement and hopefully we can get law
over the line because there's still to
this day no law law that that punishes
people for for stealing dogs
well there should be um tell me what i
can do to help uh the detective
and the thief thank you both for joining
us on the program thank you